we happened to see a mig-28 do a for g-
dive negative for G's your head would
explode hey my name is Matthew Buckley
my call signs whiz I flew the fa-18
Hornet for the United States Navy for
about 15 years I'm at home and you're
watching the breakdown first up we have
Pearl Harbor
come back
watching this gets my heart racing what
these rave guys did the morning of
December 7th 1941 reminds me of
September 11th 2001 I was getting ready
for my first flight as a pilot for
American Airlines and I was also a pilot
flying f-18 for the Naval Air Reserve
out of Naval Air Station Fort Worth
Texas and I knew we were under attack
had jumped in my car raced out to the
base one of my buddies got out there we
called down to maintenance and said
chief fuel the aircraft and we ended up
briefing in their command post and as we
were briefing two Navy guys for us 16
Air National Guard guys the Pentagon got
hit it was my December 7th was 2001 so
watching these guys get airborne and
trying to protect the United States it
definitely hits home to me very
realistic
it's my heart racing a little bit the
procedure that they're going through
right there to get into battle is pretty
accurate for the situation that they're
in clearly in fighter aviation you want
to have a planning session you want to
sit down and brief you want to tell the
maintenance crews what time you're going
to take off what type of weapon loadout
you need in the aircraft
obviously this morning all of that went
out the window this was arm the aircraft
we need to get airborne strapping in
clear everybody out of the way so
actually only five American fighter
aircraft got airborne to face that
Japanese onslaught
yeah you'd be able to see not
necessarily through the smoke
immediately when you're in it but as you
can see the Japanese pilots obviously
had situational awareness system what
was going on so from the ground it
probably looks like a lot of smoke and
they can't see well it's going to be
speeds they're moving 100 200 miles an
hour they're flying right through the
smoke so they're in it and then briefly
out of it so the smokes really no issue
to them
so this clip from Pearl Harbor is
actually very very realistic there
actually were two Army aviators that got
airborne on the morning of December 7th
George Welch and Kenneth Taylor you
gotta love these two guys they were
ready to dance and then they went to an
all-night cocktail party and as they
tell it 7:51
boom waking up to explosions two enemy
aircraft racing overhead to being
strafed and they hopped in that one
guy's Buick still had their tuxedo pants
out and they raced out to Hialeah
airfield where they amande to p40
aircraft they got airborne and Welch was
actually hit Japanese bullet hit his
canopy went into his arm and the
shrapnel went into his leg after getting
wounded the guy shot down two Japanese
aircraft they actually landed refueled
got some more ammo and got airborne
between those two absolute heroes they
shot down six enemy aircraft which was
just absolute incredible
[Music]
so that's a little sporty flying that
low
obviously there's telephone poles around
there with the telephone wire and when
you're moving at that speed if you hit a
telephone wire you can lose your rudder
or one of your control surfaces or go
straight through you but there was some
low-flying aircraft that day but that's
putting dirt on the propeller so to
speak so at this point both of them
yelling that they both have enemy
aircraft on their tail is a little of
Master the obvious at this point so it
really doesn't help too much during a
combat situation which is tense enough
already for you to be screaming over the
radio let alone telling your buddy what
he probably knows or he's going through
right now so there's a little extra
chatter over the radio at this point
which probably doesn't add to anybody's
situational awareness
[Music]
if you're dogfighting in practice and
for real you want to be as close as you
can to somebody it isn't necessarily
chicken because somebody actually has to
flinch because if you just stay pointing
at each other both gonna get credited
with a kill or a tear kill but you're
also gonna both be dead so no chicken
but makes thanks for good Hollywood so
dogfighting is a term that we use to
describe trying to get behind an enemy
opponents what we call six o'clock
directly behind them back in the day
that's how you would try and shoot down
your enemy opponent either with a gun or
a missile in today's fighter aircraft
you want to be shooting this guy down X
amount of miles away
we call it DVR beyond visual range these
guys are in a dogfight right now in what
we call wvr within visual range but this
is this is a bad day at the office
in current fighter aviation if you're
having to play chicken with the enemy
aircraft so in this scene it depicts I'd
say the bravado and the heroism of
fighter pilots your nation under attack
and in the blink of an eye reacting if
you notice in reality and in this movie
they weren't waiting for their
commanding officer to give them an order
it was time to act so the enlisted
personnel the ground crew arming the
aircraft the guys hopping in the
aircraft
that's the spirit of fighter pilots up
next we have Top Gun as a naval aviator
and a graduate of Top Gun the adversary
course if you even mention this movie in
the ready room of a fighter squadron
it's like a $50 fine or you have to buy
every guy in the squadron a drink a lot
of what goes on in this movie is just
simply unrealistic great Hollywood but
not not actually what goes on in the
Naval Aviation
I'm going from missile luck right off
the bat here the guy in back goose in
this case is what we call a Rio a radar
intercept officer who in modern aircraft
has been replaced by the computer so
right now goose is being a high-speed
cheerleader
[Music]
so what we're seeing on the screen right
now is obviously a fake Hollywood eyes
diversion of what we call the HUD the
heads-up display and what maverick is
attempting to do here and he was trying
to select what we call a Sidewinder
which is a heat-seeking missile so
you'll hear throughout the movie various
tones in maverick and goose headsets so
all over the fighter aircraft we have
like little dimples we call them so if
anybody watching as a radar detector in
their car you know that it gives
different signals and different based on
the strength and the band of radar same
thing in a fighter aircraft and the
missiles in this case a heat seeker that
we call a Sidewinder is looking for the
enemy's engine so it locks on that heat
source and when it's locked on you get
what we call a screamin tone actually in
the f-18 Hornet once it's locked up like
that it says shoot so it's got a video
proof locked up shoot so if you see the
enemy aircraft right there you heard a
little tone and that guy's headset as
well so enemy aircraft are kind of built
like our aircraft and maybe we steal
some of their plans they steal ours
they're all may be built or have the
similar systems and so in today's
Fighter environment there's what we call
secure communications or scrambled and
so it is kind of a spy versus spy
mentality it's all about trying to
disable the enemy's ability to
communicate or for their systems to work
right I've wanted to jam this guy's
radar so he can't lock me up
so even if you're a pretty high ranking
officer on an aircraft carrier
ain't no smoking on board an aircraft
carrier in the command and control
center where there's very high-tech
electronics we're not allowing any smoke
to get into those things and break down
in the 80s there was less sophisticated
technology and believe it or not in the
ready room in my fighter squadron still
had ashtrays in him fighter pilots and
smoking was kind of a thing but man that
died out a while ago so it might have
been semi acceptable on an aircraft
carrier in the 80s that definitely not
today so that tones going off in his
headset and if you notice it was kind of
a different tone than when maverick
locked up the enemy so there's different
tones in your headset and on your
displays because there's different types
of radar now if you're locked up by a
radar and they're activating their
potential missile launch now you're
gonna get a screaming tone so you
actually have to be pretty smart about
what type of tone and also it's going to
tell you based on that radar luck who it
is or what type of aircraft or weapon
that's about to get fired at as a
fighter pilot this is where we throw
some popcorn at the screen and screen if
we're watching this so the guy is
completely what we call defensive he's
got an enemy aircraft at his six o'clock
the enemy aircraft has a radar lock on
him and is about to fire and the guy's
saying hey can I can I shoot him down
the f-14 Tom in the heat in the mid to
early 80s did not have a missile that
can take off and fly behind you and
shoot the guy down behind so it's a
little comical that at this point he's
he's requesting permission to fire when
he's about to get shot down and then the
rules of engagement you have to get
fired upon in order to defend yourself
and shoot back there are some
commander-in-chief's and some what we
call ro e which is rules of engagement
that say if you get locked up by an
enemy's radar that is a target tracking
or hey you're about to get killed type
of radar that is considered a
stole a Kuenn I flew over operation
southern watch over southern Iraq that
was one of our on our checklist the
rules of engagement aren't written by
the women and men in uniform they're
written by guess what the politicians
and military attorneys so this is a
really interesting scene where hey don't
fire unless fired upon well it looks
like this guy's about to get fired upon
so the f-14 Tomcat was defined as a air
superiority fighter so the guy in the
back in this case goose he is operating
the radar system to lock up the aircraft
and obviously the pilot and he talks
over the radios so obviously maverick
the pilot stick and rudder he's flying
the airplane but in the Tomcat the the
backseater
goose could still fire an air-to-air
weapon but in this case obviously within
visual range and a dogfighting situation
the pilot maverick would be the one
shooting the gun and also firing the
missiles so it's interesting in the
movie Top Gun that we have maverick then
we're gonna be Iceman and Wolfman and
all these you know Gucci call signs so
to speak let's just say that not most
fighter pilots are running around with a
callsign that they like or gave
themselves my call signs whiz and it has
nothing to do with intelligence and I'll
leave it at that
so usually you get your callsign by
doing something stupid or it's a play on
your last name we love to call science
and Top Gun because ain't no Mavericks
or Iceman or Wolfman farther around in
navy marine or airforce aviation this is
very Hollywood ish
I'm on my way so the flying scenes just
fantastic some people sitting here hey
well you know why don't we why is he
shooting this guy right now number one
because of the rules of engagement the
guy hasn't shot yet and also because
he's got his wingman right in front of
his wing windscreen and he can't shoot
so apparently he's got to go have some
fun with him
[Music]
first of all it was a single-seat Meg
and mysteriously there's it's a two-seat
make that just I guess a guy just
magically popped up in the backseat also
if you look at about how close the two
aircraft are and some other scenes you
can see that the f-14 Tomcat the tail
has got to be at least 54 feet off the
ground we jokingly called the title of
the Tomcat the flying tennis court the
the airplane was massive so at this
point based on where the vertical
stabilizer of the f-14 would be they
would have already had a mid-air
collision so this is just epically
hysterical at this point obviously very
Hollywood eyes you wouldn't be doing
something like this later in the movie
one of the funniest lines in this movie
is hey you were in a negative for G dive
with a mig-28 so if you don't know what
negative G's R is like when you you're
flying over the railroad tracks and and
you get light in your seat or at the top
of a roller coaster it's it's we call it
eyes out G meaning positive G the Bloods
leaving your head and you can pass out
negative G the blood is actually going
into your head and we call it eyes out G
because he'll your eyes could pop out at
a certain point a negative G negative
couple jeez that's painful
I mean I've had broken blood vessels in
my eyes because of this negative 4 G's
your head would explode it is so and not
only negative 4 G's with your head pop
off its brain stem
they said you're in a negative for G
dive it's physiologically and physically
impossible to do what is depicted
I crack myself up since your goose and
you have nothing else to do as a
backseater you probably would bring a
Polaroid but now so we did have a camera
that we take in the f-18 because you did
need to take pictures sometimes of you
know an enemy aircraft you'd intercept
or even a suspicious vessel so Polaroid
not so much real camera yeah we'd
actually have cameras in the aircraft I
was a junior in high school when the
first movie came out and I knew since I
wanted to breathe I wanted to be a Navy
fighter pilot all of a sudden this movie
came out and everybody including my
mother wanted to be a Navy fighter pilot
so it was great for recruiting for
fighter aviation it's great theater we
love it but at the end of the day
maverick women lasted five minutes in a
real fighter squadron I can't wait to
see the the new one so I have a couple
buddies who did a lot of the flying it's
going to be good
next up behind enemy lines
[Music]
okay so great clip here and behind enemy
lines first of all this has got to be
the longest time I've ever seen a
surface-to-air missile fly these things
can fly some of them five times faster
than a fighter jet but this one seems to
be able to fly for about an hour here
and what we just saw was this f-18 put
out a bunch of flares and also what we
call chaff and also jamming pods if
you're a heat-seeking missile you're
staring at this engine heat I'm gonna go
hit that engine and blow it up and all
of a sudden a bunch of hotter things pop
out if it's a radar missile and you're
going after an aircraft and you're
locked on and all of a sudden you see a
bigger radar image pop up maybe you'll
go lock on to that and away from the
aircraft and the final thing that might
be popping out of this aircraft is what
we call jammers so little electronic
jammers that hopefully scramble this
missiles brains and make it not hit you
so at this point these guys in this f-18
F are defensive they have the next 10
seconds of their life to try and decoy
this missile so back on board the ship
that's the probably what we call CIC the
combat Information Center is at the
heart of an aircraft carrier or a
surface ship wherever the combatant
commander is so whoever wherever the
Admiral is or the commander of the
battle group that's all that blue
lighting or red lighting and all the
sensors in that room they're probably
writing down the aircraft's position
time and getting the stats of what's
going on in this engagement
so this is a little bit more realistic
than Top Gun you can see a little bit
more that displays inside the aircraft
it's tracking at you and giving you a
little distance so you can tell the
technology advantage that we have in the
f-18 Hornet then we did over the f-14
still in this movie behind enemy lines
we got a goose in the back this time
another radar intercept officer
they changed the term from Rio to WIZO
weapons system operator so this guy in
the back right now talking over the
radio putting out chaff and flare and
trying to help the pilot with some
situational awareness but a little a
little better than the movie Top Gun you
can see what's going on in the aircraft
so as I said we're on about our to of
this missile flying surface-to-air
missiles man are fast and like I said
some of them five times faster than I
can going downhill with a tailwind so
these things probably would have hit
them by now but if you can look out over
your shoulder and see this missile kind
of hanging out and just barely closing
it's a little cartoonish at this point
but you know it's it's it's Hollywood
he's probably either trying to be
supersonic or subsonic we have a saying
in fighter aviation that speed is life
you can always get rid of airspeed you
can always pull GE or pull the throttles
back
so the mask the main reason you're
wearing a mask obviously clearly is
oxygen if it's needed at higher
altitudes but also for communication so
your microphone is in fact in the mask
and the mask is held onto your face
obviously by the helmet the helmets not
for like crash protection it's not super
durable it's just a helmet that has ear
cups and then your mask has the
microphone in it and your breathing
percent oxygen at that point so let's go
back a little bit I want to take a look
at this when you're talking about the
movie Top Gun there was a couple times
in the movie for example when maverick
touched down on the flight deck pulled
back on the stick and pulled back on the
throttles to get airborne last time I
checked flying the f-18 when you pull
back on the throttles the power goes
back so he would have fallen off the the
aircraft flight deck so in this scene
right here he's dropping his drop tanks
to blow them up to maybe decoy these
enemy heat-seeking missiles watch what
he also does he actually pulls back two
throttles and you can see the
afterburners go out so now big fireball
and the heat-seeking missiles are going
to go after that instead of his aircraft
so clearly these weren't radar seeking
missiles right they were heat-seeking
missiles if they got decoy by that heat
it's not possible to outrun it it could
be possible to outmaneuver it or to
decoy it with the chaff the flares or
the jammers you're not gonna have her on
a missile most missiles are faster than
they fastest aircraft on this planet
there are technology out there where it
says hey I'm seeing a bunch of stuff
flying out of this airplane that's hot
maybe I should ignore those and stick
with the aircraft I haven't flown in a
long time so that technology is probably
way past at wherever I was lying
so one of the missiles got decoyed by
the fireball there's a finite amount of
rocket fuel in this thing and it's been
flying for a good calendar year right
now somebody's gonna gonna have a really
bad day here because the second one did
[Music]
so as a fighter pilot you have to be in
top shape top physical shape especially
your legs and your stomach because as
you pull positive genes the blood is
rushing out of your heads it's called
the hitch maneuver so you want to
squeeze your legs and your abs to
squeeze the blood to keep it in your
head what's the first thing that goes
when you pass out your vision we would
fight the jet on the edge of
consciousness I pull a lot of G's and
I'd fight the jet on the edge of what we
call grey out I can still fly I'm still
talking over the radio maneuvering my
hands but I'm actually losing sight of
the guy so as I kind of gray out I'll
unload a little bit let some blood get
back into my vision oh there he is and
pull even more that's how much you want
to win and you're also wearing what we
call a G suit they look like very very
tight jeans so to speak go over your
flight suit and they're actually plugged
into the aircraft and they use engine
bleed air so the more G I pull these
jeans inflate and they squeeze your legs
even more so you can see in this air to
air engagement it's very very physically
demanding also during this as you're
seeing these guys maneuver the
adrenaline rush is through the roof they
got the next couple seconds of their
lives literally to defeat this thing so
you're really not even feeling the
physiological effects of the G's at this
point it's just doing it so behind enemy
lines compared to Top Gun definitely a
lot more realistic and a little bit more
of the discipline and also the
search-and-rescue it shows the more Navy
Marine Corps team hey folks thanks for
watching these clips with me stand by
for part two and be safe out there
you